- My personal style in three
words is goofy, teacher, boy.
(upbeat music)
- I think my personal style is dapper,
it's sexy, it's functional.
I really want people to see
that I'm like a creative,
I'm a dreamer, I'm like a powerful woman,
you know, someone who is out
here and just killing it.
- I like to combine both masculine
and feminine energies in the way I dress.
Anyone can buy fashion,
anyone can learn fashion
down at the school, but style
is something that is internal
that you carry with you throughout life.
I'm all about my style, baby.
- I've always dressed on the
more masculine side of things.
It was cargo shorts in
middle school and then again
in college and now thank God
the cargo shorts are gone.
- My clothes make me feel confident,
they make me feel like myself.
They make me feel joyful.
- I feel like gender is fluidity
as has been said a million
times over and over again,
but it's truth, and my gender is fluidity.
Being a bigger body, it's
harder to find things
that feel like they have the right fit
and feel like they're
the right style for me.
- When I was growing up, I wore
a lot of dresses and heels,
and I looked very nice in them,
but it just wasn't what
I was comfortable in.
- Sometimes I might have something long
and very extremely feminine, but sometimes
I'll do a dungaree or a jumper
and a baseball cap to the back.
It really depends on my mood.
- I want my clothes to make me feel
like the sort of goofy,
butchy mask that I am.
- I don't shop at stores too often.
It's very difficult to
find anything there for me,
but I hope that anyone who
looks at me is inspired
to do whatever they want
to do to express themselves
and not ask for anyone's permission.
- I would have to say Jaden
Smith is the fashion icon.
Dresses and flower crowns.
Boys in dresses, boys in dresses.
- Who-Ha.
(laughing)
- I think non-binary
fashion to me is freedom.
I would love to walk into a store
and it's not based on men's
section, women's section,
but really about the styles and the fits
and the different body types.
- No bounds, no walls, there's
no rules, there's no limits.
Being an androgynous
person, like I don't care.
If I like it, I'm gonna wear it.
I'm gonna match it and style it
so it fits my body and my lifestyle.
- I think non-binary
fashion is just like a game
of figuring out how I feel in a moment.
- It allows us to dress ourselves
the way we see ourselves within
and the way we feel within.
- You know, clothing is based
off of societal constructs
and so my expression of
that doesn't have to be
what other people want me to look like.
- Masculinity is just so fragile
that any kind of change
towards it is just a oh my God.
- I think it's really brave for people
to make the choice on a daily
or a weekly or a monthly basis
to dress in a way that fits
their authentic selves.
(upbeat music)
We can see queerly here
(laughing)
that gender is a complicated construct.